so ugc which is user generated content
has exploded in 2022 and then now more
so in 2023 where not only us as creators
but a brand will come to us and ask us
to create 15 second video one or two but
now it's become this like hey create 10
videos a month and people are getting
paid like this regular salary from a
brand to create content how are they
getting in touch with these Brands to
make ugc for them in a paid fashion yeah
so the number one way is by creating
content on Tick Tock people don't really
realize the power of how many companies
are searching Tick Tock for a Creator
they don't really it's like it's
thousands and thousands of people every
day looking for creators on the platform
and mostly it's not necessarily Nike
it's the agency that does marketing for
uh for Nike so they have this person who
they are searching looking for a man or
a woman or whatever or uh whatever
they're looking for and it's this
Creator who they're they're seeing the
and it's not always about this person
has the biggest following it's about
does this person look good on camera
does this person have a clean enough
brand but we can have them represent our
company so first creating content on
Tick Tock but the second most powerful
way is having your profile in these
influencer marketing agencies database
so there's thousands of companies that
do influence of marketing and me on a
regular basis I do a couple things one
I'm always on Google typing in
influencer marketing agencies and if a
new one pops up I go to their website I
click on influencer and I just set up a
set up a profile where it's me it's my
account it's what I do yada yada and
then it's in there and what ends up
happening is that this agency then has
this company that wants to work with
them and they are looking for a person
like me and they're able to do it like a
filter search in their database they
find me and then they contact me so like
it's work of like finding all these
agencies and putting up your profile but
I've made almost 150 000 doing it that
way just having my profile set up